j'ai peur vraiment j'ai peur de jouer à
ce jeu j'ai pas peur de m'énerver mais
au delà du stade de la colère il ya le
stade de la déprime est vraiment ce jeu
est déprimant on dirait un genre de test
d'évaluation de résistance au suicide
créé par des thérapeutes pour des
soldats capturés à la guerre je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
cauchemar un cauchemar horrible et
incohérent et la mauvaise musique que
vous entendez la compétence rigoureux
c'est le prélude à l'ouverture des
portes
bon alors d'après ce que j'ai cru
comprendre vous êtes duncan pas là d'un
brave et courageux sans peur qu'ils se
jettent à l'assaut du dark castle pour
aller affronter le chevalier noir mais
malheureusement duncan est aussi un peu
con vous n'avez aucune armée aucune
armure seulement des petits cailloux
bon allez donc au début du jeu vous
devez choisir une des ailes du donjon
pour récupérer armes et armures pour
ensuite affronter le boss dans la halle
centrale
bizarrement la lure de votre personnage
me fait un peu penser à ça me de scooby
doo ce qui pourrait expliquer qu'il soit
un peu neuneu et suis crevé je suis
corriger j'ai subi ou refusé de
cautionner un demi finale et je vais
partir à gauche
le jeu se présente sous la forme d'une
succession de tableaux vous disposez de
trois touches c'est pour jeter des
cailloux mais pour ramasser ou se
baisser et à pour
est ce que je viens de mourir d'une
chute dans les escaliers sérieusement
est-ce que c'est une blague là je suis
mort en tombant
trois matches c'est censé être chevalier
pas une grand mère estropiés le système
de visée est un des plus ridicules de
l'histoire des jeux vidéo
contrairement à n'importe quel jeu
existant nous appuyer sur la touche pour
tirer en pressant la bonne combinaison
sur le pavé directionnel ici vous devez
d'abord choisir l'angle de tir en
bougeant votre bras de haut en bas puis
seulement ensuite appuyé sur le bouton
pour tirer
non seulement ça absolument pas
ergonomique mais en plus le bras de
votre personnage est remonté comme une
pendule et les diplômes va faire le
mouvement d'autant bas impossible de
réagir rapidement quand vous êtes
entourés d'ennemis et là c'est le drame
pourquoi à part tous les dieux des jeux
vidéo ont ils mis au système de visée
comme ça alors que ça serait tellement
plus simple d'avoir un système de visée
comme il existe dans tous les autres
jeux vidéo du monde sérieusement le pire
dans tout ça c'est que si seulement ça
ferme était de mieux viser encore je
veux bien mais là c'est même pas le cas
parfois vous avez des ennemis qui sont
dans un angle impossible à atteindre
évidemment on retrouve dans ce jeu les
clichés habituels des jeux d'horreur les
chauves-souris qui vous tuent des
qu'elle frôle vos cheveux les rats qui
vous mordit un orteil tellement fort
comme gens mourir sur le coup
les zombies qui ressemble à frankenstein
équipe tire avec un flingue mais
vraiment vraiment il existe quelque
chose de bien pire dans ce donjon
[Musique]
tralala
manning
ouais bon donc pas la peine de
s'acharner à le lapider je suppose qu'il
faut ramasser ce truc qui ressemble à
une masse disant mais en fait la
première fois que j'ai test le jeu moi
je croyais que ça faisait partie du
décor
les [ __ ] [ __ ] ramasse board of art
et le cul mais tu vas la ramasse et
cette [ __ ] de masse le système pour
ramasser des objets ou interagir avec
est purement ignoble pour ramasser des
objets il faut avoir le bras b c au
maximum c'est une stupidité
astronomiques
quel est l'intérêt de faire ça pourquoi
une simple touche ne pourrait pas
ramasser un objet tout simplement et
c'est exactement pareil pour grimper à
certaines cordes on ne sait jamais si on
en train de faire quelque chose
techniquement possible ou si on est en
train de faire quelque chose
d'irréalisable jusqu'à ce qu'on
réussisse par hasard à les montrent au
[ __ ] je te hais je hais toute ta
famille mes enfants tu as un colosse de
cordes un jeu tu aimerais être simple à
utiliser je vois l'objet je marche
dessus ça les horaires
ouais j'ai finalement réussi à ramasser
la masse au bout de plusieurs minutes et
en fait totalement par hasard
et là vous allez voir le combat le plus
épique jamais vu sur megadrive
[Musique]
m
voilà c'était épique
et je ramasse les deux clés je me tire
de ce [ __ ] de
[Musique]
une minute
je ramasse la clé et je sors me retape
en tout le chemin à l'envers
[Musique]
voilà ça y est je suis sorti j'ai fini
le jeu allait finir un horrible doute
m'envahit il en fait je veux dire je
suis rentré dans le donjon
j'ai pris la clef et j'en suis sorti ok
cool mais après je savais à quoi elles
seront les armes les armures chaque
tableaux s'enchaînent le après l'autre
c'est toujours le même principe
contrairement à d'autres jeux où chaque
ennemi aurait un move inscrits et ce qui
permettrait de savoir quoi faire au bout
de quelques tentatives en connaissant
les mouvements ennemis elle avance là ça
a plutôt l'air d'être un report
aléatoire et c'est très handicapant
surtout quand vous avez l'andra qui
décide de se mettre un endroit gênant et
de ne plus en bouger
voilà j'ai fini par trouver le bouclier
bon ok je fais quoi maintenant j'attends
de faire électrocuter
[Musique]
aves ok ça me renvoie au début bon
voyons dans un autre truc là ok
maintenant le bouton b me permet de
devenir un super guerrier de l'espace de
garder ça ouais c'est naze mais je
commence très sérieusement avant des
problèmes mentaux à force de jouer à ce
jeu john kent et le héros le plus
pathétique de toute l'histoire des jeux
vidéo regardez ça qui a entendu parler
d'un paladin qui se vautre en descendant
une marche haute de 7 cm sérieusement
bref donc une petite souris m'a tuer en
me grignotant à mort pendant que mon
héros se remettait d'une chute
haute de 7 cm je pense que cette phrase
résume assez bien le jeu dans son
ensemble
parlons un peu musique maintenant si
vous êtes aussi culture et que moi vous
aurez évidemment reconnu la mélodie de
jean sébastien bach toccata et fugue en
des mineurs merci wikipédia je te fais
pas dire et ça fait un peu bizarre
d'entendre de la musique classique comme
ça dans un jeu mais au bout d'un moment
ça commence vraiment à vous vriller les
tympans heureusement on peut la
désactiver à tout moment
[Musique]
en fait couper la musique chez eux ça
veut juste dire gelé la note en cours
des fois on tombe sur des trucs bizarres
on se demande si même les développeurs
n'avaient pas pété les plombs quoi dans
le jeux gamers rules saddam loisir
qu'est ce que c'est que ça j'arrive
enfin au chevalier noir et c'est
certainement le boss le plus épique que
vous n'avez jamais vu un ivrogne qui me
balance des chopes de bière en
dégueulant
bon allez j'insiste un peu quand même
après tout je vais enfin voir la fin du
jeu c'est pas trop tôt c'est le premier
jeu que je termine le jeu n'est pas
extrêmement dur quand on a chopé le coup
mais les contrôles sont tellement à
chier que c'est un exploit d'y arriver
[Musique]
c'est tout
quand j'y repense à l'époque je sais pas
pourquoi on s'acharnait à finir ce genre
de jeu je veux dire c'est pas comme si
on s'attendait à avoir une scène
cinématique à la fin et pourtant malgré
ça on insisté en fait c'est plutôt un
écran de faim comme ça qui devrait ya
voir dark castle a existé sur apple com
d'or 64 et amiga entre autres la version
megadrive auraient dû être meilleures
autant graphiquement que sur les
consoles mais ça n'a pas été le cas et
je préfère même pas vous parler de
l'absence de sauvegarde qui vous oblige
à vous taper tout le jeu d'un seul trait
alors pour un jeu comme ça le seul
châtiment
non je vais pas le cas c'est en fait je
veux dire bon oui c'est vrai les
contrôles sont horribles mais les
éditeurs ont voulu rester trop fidèle
aux anciennes versions
je vais lui accorder ma grâce
exceptionnelle finalement aller à la
prochaine
allez c'est bon c'est bon
[Musique]
le